hi everyone welcome to one nation i'm
brian kilmeade it's the rise of the
reasonable some of the most powerful
voices in america today are popular not
because of what they were known for in
the past not for their crazy or moderate
views but for their reasonable takes in
my view and for being reasonable as
people and they are labeled radical
because they're reasonable follow me
let's take a look at people like the
people behind me like joe rogan joe
manchin bill maher and elon musk they
are everywhere and they haven't changed
over the years the media has to be more
divisive than ever but people are sick
of it i believe joe rogan's insanely
popular you don't need me to tell you
that even despite the left trying to
cancel him a couple of times but rogan
admits it's not because he's all of a
sudden a wealth of knowledge
when i say something stupid i'm not
thinking about what i'm going to say
before i say it and i'm a cage-fighting
commentator who's a dirty stand-up
comedian i'm not a respected source of
information even for me
i at least try to be honest about what
i'm saying thank you bill moore he's a
liberal he's always been and nowadays
everyone kind of likes them especially
on the right i am still the same
unmarried childless pot-smoking
libertine i always was
i have many flaws but you can't accuse
me of maturing
let's get this straight it's not me
who's changed it's the left
who is now made up of a small contingent
who've gone mental and a large
contingent who refused to call them out
for it but i will
he is honest and he isn't afraid to
stand for what's right regardless of his
party he doesn't care what you think he
even has come out against liberal outcry
over the florida's new educational bill
remember this
you know as always with this stuff
you know this
not like there's no kernel of truth in
that maybe kids that young
shouldn't be thinking about sex at all
you think
people respect that and the average
american is responding to these
reasonable people even if you don't
agree look at joe manchin his approval
rating has skyrocketed 17 over the last
year no other democrat has done that
other dems may want to label him a
radical but he's reasonable and has
stood in the way of joe biden's agenda
because it hasn't been reasonable he's
been the same democrat all along i've
never changed martha i'm the same person
i have been all my life i look for that
moderate middle the common sense that
comes with the moderate middles who i am
that's what people expect and then
there's elon musk he's getting hammered
this week by the left for his takeover
of twitter
but it's not because he's conservative
he's never been he just tells it like it
is musk tweeted this right behind me
this week he says i supported obama for
president but today's democratic party
has been hijacked by extremists the
message that musk is not some crazy
conservative has not quite gotten
through to certain people on certain
channels look at this
elon musk calls himself a free speech
absolutist well first of all that's bs
it seems to me that it's about free
speech of straight
white men if you own all of twitter or
facebook or what have you
you don't have to explain yourself elon
musk buying twitter says a lot about the
priorities of people at the highest
levels making decisions that could
affect the fate of the planet elon musk
i guess he you know he misses the old
south africa in the 80s he wants he
wants that back
that's insanity especially that last
comment the libertarian who shows he's
more sane than squad which makes him
somehow too radical even the left should
love him because remember tesla that's
the greenest vehicle in the world maybe
the best as unorthodox as some of his
antics are as you're seeing behind me
he's proposing reasonable things like
true freedom of speech for the future of
social media these people i mentioned
are just some examples of the reasonable
they haven't changed over the years
their parties have but their rising
popularity show me the country has not
so
are we finally snapping out of our
political polarization with the rise of
the radical reasonable hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now